you
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescent flows from strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescent
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman he is a baby
david patman he is
patman
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta
that's a lot that's a lot of fun with
everything that's raw abortion they
think
a woman a beta male died but another
baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody um we have a
really
exciting stream today for a few
different reasons number one
we are already having to ban so many
people
merely the fact that joe biden is going
to be signing into law juneteenth as a
federal holiday
it's already triggering people and we're
getting massive dumps of conservatives
in the chat and we're banning them all
when they do
crazy stuff but if you just have a
respectful disagreement
that's no big deal number two i have
today for the first time
i have my elgato stream deck this is a
new
technical element that we're introducing
into the streams
because the streams are getting so
complicated we actually had
um we had a computer science a group of
computer science phds come in and look
at everything and they said this is way
too complicated
you need a stream deck and uh because
what's happening sometimes is
when i use numbers on the keyboard to
change between
scenes like for example you know from
this scene to this scene maybe to this
scene
back one two
um sometimes if i have a youtube video
up if you press like six
like six goes to the 50 mark of the
video and it's it's not good
it's not good so the elgato stream deck
allows me
like as you can see here i can go to me
full
or the one that works for the youtube
shot or if i'm looking at a full page or
all of this stuff
so we already are having technical
issues with it
for example one of the things i did was
set up
when the second youtube channel comes up
people may be aware
uh of the second youtube channel which
we are i want to get to 5 000
subscribers on it today
and when the channel comes up people say
what is the link i set up a button
to just put the link in the youtube and
twitch chat
boom i just pressed it now it's working
in twitch
i don't know why it's not working in
youtube for whatever reason
when i try to sync my stream deck with
youtube it syncs it with my youtube
oh wait there it is oh it worked
okay forget about it it's fixed it's
fixed okay great
so that's something so anyway if people
are familiar with the stream deck and
you guys want to give me
you know some ideas as to what other
things i want to program in
i would love that i have now
if we need to dump literally i have a
dumps button
and this is what happens when i hit the
dumps button if there is
anything that needs to be satirized and
remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way okay so like if we had an
emergency dump moment i would be able to
dump to that
um i have programmed in the trump 100. i
just don't know about q anon
you do know i don't know no i don't know
you know if you go out
i like that idea i should have a button
that would play
ymca that's actually a really good idea
let me think how i would do that i guess
what i would do is i would download the
track
let's just see if we can do it um
if i go to youtube and i just go to
ymca uh okay i've got a link
copy link so then i can do youtube
downloader let's just test we're kind of
testing it all out
a lot of these downloaders let you
download just as an mp3 let's see if i
can do that
mp3 perfect get link download
so now i'm saving villagepeopleymca.mp3
we're learning about the guys stop with
the dmca stuff please
please that's the most annoying
meta trend on twitch which is anybody
anytime anybody talks about a
song people go completely crazy dmca
okay so um i guess this would be
a system command multimedia
and we'll drop that in the title will be
ymca
the action will be
uh hmm play pause
no i need to set up a specific track
this isn't it let's see oh
sound board hold on here it is play
audio
and we will call it ymca
we will select our ymca file this is
just we're testing things guys
this is how we we iterate play stop with
no fade
okay good so i've programmed in a ymca
let's just see what happens
right and if i press it again it stops
beautiful so we're developing
content here guys i appreciate that i
appreciate the donation from steven
robbins towards the stream deck
very very powerful no but in all
seriousness if people do
if people who are more experienced with
stream deck want to send me info
davidpakman.com
let me know
okay so we've got that um
it does start over yeah that's true so
if i it looks like if i pause it then it
starts over
that's okay that's okay i can set up
another button
that would just be a play pause button
but it's like how many buttons do we
really need here
okay very good so we're standing by
for that and all other
things let me look at a few super chats
pepe says why did you stop shopping at
walmart i haven't been to a walmart in
15 years
at the time i didn't like what walmart
was doing politically and from the
standpoint of the minimum wage and
benefits i found walmart to be the
corporate equivalent of grifters
and so i haven't been there since jacob
likes the hat
tristan asks if i'm golfing pepe asks if
i've
been mistaken for caucasian growing up
yes i have been
the right loves to remind me i'm not a
white guy
whereas the left loves to remind me i'm
a privileged white guy
aaron says i'm happy the south lost the
civil war
never thought that would be
controversial
um jesus or jesus says that the hat
makes me look alpha
beautiful that's the goal scott says my
us
embassy emergency appointment for
tomorrow got cancelled at seven could
the government have done this with more
than five minutes notice
i don't know anything about that joseph
says what do you think of manchin's list
of voting rights issues he would support
there's been reporting from new york
times he might be coming around on the
filibuster too good to be true
no i think it's quite possible today in
fact i interviewed ro khanna
or as some say ro khanna and we actually
talked about mansion
i think people will like that jay says
sir where did you get the very powerful
hat from
should i say because they're not a
sponsor
i just wanted a white hat so i bought it
i'm not going to say i don't want to say
jeffrey says great stream david thank
you we're only just getting started and
peppy says this was tech talk
with david pakman marjorie taylor pakman
says imagine in 2014 someone said trump
will become president be impeached twice
and cite an insurrection and a global
pandemic
we'll kill 600 000 americans we wouldn't
have believed it
we wouldn't have believed it
tino says this is my request for a fraud
sound button if someone can get me a
clean audio
of trump saying fraud i will add it to
my sound board i would be glad to do
that
david hatman yes very obvious very
obvious okay
let's just get into stuff because we
don't have unlimited time
um let's jump right in here
browser here we go here i've got a few
things to run through
here is mike pillow oh sorry sorry sorry
i do need to
i'm missing some thank yous hold on
kathleen rodriguez just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and john wood just signed up at
joinpackman.com that's new members one
and two
also over on twitch i want to say thank
you to altea's rich
nathan's
blaze king crazy hawaiian in pa
crazy hawaiian npa also for the upgrade
master mcleavy
confirm or disconfirm
for the twitch subs putting us at eight
we do have a special coupon code today
in honor of juneteenth the code is
juneteenth
it gives you a membership for just 19
bucks
or a dollar 90 a month the trick though
is you have to know how to spell
juneteenth and i'm not going to tell you
so if you don't know how to spell
juneteenth you can't take advantage of
that code
all right here's mike pillow here's he
now he says trump really won cali
in california there was so much organic
cheating
that actually donald trump did organic
cheating not
inorganic cheating you really need to
understand chemistry actually
to know what it is that went on there in
california
and that you know but that's a
subjective number but there was
there was so much done kind of like
nevada
there was so much organic cheating in
nevada is this glenn beck who is this
guy
okay there were seven different ways of
cheating went on in nevada
seven ways to sunday things were cheated
so there's mike pillow
um so there's that here's
adults full grown men and women
harassing children
about the fact that they're wearing a
mask
what are you doing out here look at
these idiot's faces
where's your parents at they have you
out here masked you don't need to wear
them you know that why are you wearing
it
why the hell you wearing a mask out
where's your mom and dad
what cdc said we cdc says you're going
to die
yeah how come you ain't dead yet yeah
how come you're not dead
defiant and principled questioning as to
why these kids are alive
how did you survive children so that's
adults
that's adults now i want to go over
uh the genesis of disinformation
propaganda
okay i'm going to walk you guys through
and hold on i do want to make sure we
don't
miss the biden event okay we've got
audio turned up here
um and multiple streams in case only one
goes live
here is how complete nonsense generates
and then it starts to become used almost
as evidence nonsense becomes used as
evidence for more nonsense okay
so we looked at this yesterday here's
tucker carlson's new idea that the fbi
did the trump riots now i don't actually
think
tucker believes this i think tucker
knows his audience will believe it
and it'll get him ratings i don't think
tucker is this stupid
but here's tucker's new idea but
strangely some of the key people who
participated
on january 6 have not been charged
look at the documents the government
calls those people unindicted
co-conspirators what does that mean
well it means that in potentially every
single case they were fbi operatives
okay so look at the language the fact
that there are unnamed
as yet unindicted co-conspirators
involved in some of these 400 cases
might mean that they're all fbi agents
now it might mean
nothing it might mean that they are
cases that are still pending
it might mean that there are a whole
bunch of other reasons why there are
unindicted co-conspirators not named
right so far but it could be that the
fbi ran the entire riots
tucker's just asking questions in the
capital on january 6th
right for example one of those
unindicted co-conspirators is someone
government documents identify only as
person two
whoa according to those documents person
two stayed in the same hotel room as a
man called thomas caldwell reportedly
they even did head to toe they shared a
bed and did head to toe and that
they they were gonna do back to back and
they did head to toe and that's a real
signal that these guys could be bad
people
insurrectionist a man alleged to be a
member of the group
the oath keepers person two also quote
stormed the barricades at the capitol on
january 6
alongside thomas caldwell the
government's indictments further
indicate that caldwell who by the way is
a 65 year old man
yes dangerous insurrectionist was led to
believe there would be a quote
quick reaction force also participating
on january 6th
that quick reaction force caldwell was
told would be led by someone called
person 3
who had a hotel room and an accomplice
with them whoa
but wait here's the interesting thing
person two
and person three were organizers of the
riot
remember he still put forward no
evidence that these are
fbi agents right he he's telling us a
lot of things about what we don't know
and then he goes these might all just be
fbi agents
the government knows who they are but
the government has not
charged them why is that
you know why they were almost certainly
working for the fbi
almost certainly so you really need to
do
a linguistic analysis you need a
transcript almost certainly
but i have no evidence whatsoever for
that claim
so fbi operatives were organizing
the attack on the capitol did you see
what he did there
twice he says they quite possibly might
be
fbi agents it's conceivable that they're
all fbi agents and then he uses that to
say
fbi agents organized the riots
on january 6th according to government
documents
the government documents don't say that
the government documents simply say
these people have not yet been indicted
and we're not referring to them by name
yet and those two are not alone
in all revolver news reported there are
quote upwards of
20 unindicted co-cons okay so this was
the start two days ago
now there's no evidence presented here
other than revolver
which is just a right wing bomb throwing
website revolver wrote an article
so now we get to last night okay here
and i'm going to cue this up exactly
where we want it here
tucker brings on the guy from revolver
and now look at what happens okay now
pay attention remember tucker
tuesday night was based on this guy's
report now we've got the guy
let's listen to what the guy says over
news we're glad to see him tonight
darren thanks so much
for coming on it sounds like according
to this
i have to say remarkable piece that you
just put up late last night
read it in bed at midnight that the fbi
was organizing the riots so tucker says
it sounds like it now let's see what
evidence does this guy have to put
forward
of january 6th
well yes it certainly suggests that
possibility and i did you guys hear that
it certainly suggests
that what was the word possibility
so tucker's entire rant from tuesday
is based off of this report and all this
guy can say
is that there is a suggestion of a
possibility
a suggestion of a possibility i'm
hearing from people that this
is the most important and the darkest
investigative piece they've seen in
years he's hearing from people
who again have read his assertions which
have no evidence
and they're reacting by saying you know
darren this is the darkest investigation
we've ever heard of
there have been no facts presented
whatsoever so
that's wednesday now we get to thursday
this was earlier today louis gomer now
says if there were federal agents
involved we really need to know
all about what the fbi was doing again
nobody's presented evidence
tucker mentions it based on what darren
beatty
said is possible without evidence now
louie gohmert on the floor of the house
we're tracking the disinformation right
you know
so if there were federal agents that
were
involved on january 6 if
we really need to know this is not
slowed down by the way this is normal
speed normal i mean
it's it's one x it's not normal but
what the fbi knew and when they knew it
and not only that
we need to know how much participation
did any of our federal friends either
at doj fbi sure we need to know that
but nobody has actually presented
any evidence yet that we should believe
that that happened we've got tucker
based on darren who has no evidence now
louis wants an investigation it's
a runaway freight train okay and then
here
is sheriff david clarke now
demanding that congress establish an
independent commission
to investigate the fbi it it all goes
back to nothing
there's nothing there but here's sheriff
clark saying anything short of an
investigation by the way led by alan
dershowitz
indistinguishable from parody it's not
an outside commission you cannot have
the senate judiciary do this they don't
know how and they're afraid
of what the fbi might have on them that
they they might leak
so you need an outside commission a
panel my suggestion for example would be
that this should be headed by ellen
thurstowitz
yeah so how did so now we're
on day three where did this come from
it came from tucker reading an article
in bed at midnight
might have been on ambien for all we
know and then doing a story about it
getting pushback so he brings on the guy
who wrote the story
and that guy says well there's
definitely a suggestion of a possibility
next thing you know it's on the house
floor and then this guy is saying
alan dershowitz needs to run an invent
an investigation
that is the uh genesis and the path
of this disinformation propaganda and
there's just
there's still nothing there now
if i'm not you know there's some on the
revolutionary left who love to say
as soon as trump became president
so-called liberals
were falling all over themselves to say
the fbi is great
and the cia is great that's not what
this is about
if the fbi organized the trump riots i
want to know it
if the trump white house organized the
trump riots as alex jones claims
i want to know it i don't care i don't
i'm not looking to protect anybody or or
anything of the sort
but no evidence has been put forward at
this point in time it's tucker based on
darren
signal boosted by louis and then now
dershowitz uh
you know etc etc um so that's the
genesis of it i think you guys get it
and
and we can move on uh oh and yeah and by
the way
republicans had the opportunity to
support a commission
and they all are against it um so i'm
glad that that's being pointed out as
well
i want to say thank you to jonathan
smith who just signed up with the coupon
code
juneteenth at joinpakman.com we have a
special coupon code today
through juneteenth uh to celebrate
juneteenth
you can use it at joinpakman.com the
discount is ungodly
but you do need to know how to spell
juneteenth so far only one person has
figured it out
uh jonathan smith thank you so much for
signing up on my website your new member
number nine
also want to say thank you to liquid ice
sue me
long astro lycos and paranoid
for signing up via twitch in new members
10 11 12 and 13 today
there are constitutional questions about
the legality of this coupon code it's
more of a
it's not clear who has standing to bring
it forward but there are definitely some
constitutional issues
um okay let's yeah let me do a few other
super chats i see i'm falling behind
here
um
trans rights are human rights says
kobach cobalt
cobalt happy pride month yes justin says
sir i believe a juneteenth holiday is an
upgrade
from when trump did a rally in oklahoma
on juneteenth yeah that was a mess
that was a mess
i'm not even going to read this from
james freeland it's just a little too
edgy for me
bay photo says how does tucker's show
not come with a legal disclaimer
we know his employer confirmed he's full
of bs in court
absolutely many q anon people are
running for seats in 22 how do you think
this will affect misinformation in 24
will it help or hurt republicans
we won't know until we see how well the
q people do in 2022
it's our job to make sure they don't do
well but can't answer about 24 until we
see what happens in 22.
marjorie taylor pacman says lorazepam
louis has to slow down a bit too
strong yeah he was really shot out of a
cannon
and avi says a tan hat really pac-man
what's next a tan suit
this is off-white i think it's called
cream actually
it's not i know that that's not
necessarily the most alpha color but
that's what it is unban requests i have
i have none i have no unban requests for
you guys today
i do have some voicemails and i'm glad
to look at those
um this is all new new stuff
let's see what we've got here
um a lot of these i'm skipping because
they're not
so good
let's take a listen here we go hello
david
hey i'm not an economist but i've
come to my attention that china does not
own most of our debt they only own
a very small percentage of it it's
mostly
owned by americans with bonds so
i was wondering is this true as far as
you know yeah and it's actually
i don't even think china owns the
majority of our foreign debt
u.s foreign debt by country
i believe it's japan um
let's take a look here
so in 2019 it was just barely china over
japan
yeah no but it's it's it's a very good
point and
nobody talks about japan it's very close
between japan and china
maybe japan who holds more of our debt
now obviously there are political
reasons
why people focus more on china than
japan china has seen more of an
adversary and a challenger as a
along with russia as a superpower and
there's foreign policy reasons but the
caller is absolutely right nice
voicemail
um let's listen to one more hi
david i want to thank you for all your
insightful math oriented
graphics and uh you're educating the
public
on looking up stuff so what was that
thing you showed i guess it's called a
scattergram
and it had three boxes and x-axis the
y-axis
and one box only had four states in it
and you said you didn't know why
oregon washington uh maine and i think
you said colorado
have high vaccine rates but also
surprisingly high new covid cases per
100 000 population so uh
you know when you put those graphics up
and then i couldn't find it so
could you please let us know where you
from man okay so people asking for
specific graphics
um you'll have to watch the clip i think
um let's see another another voicemail
hello david i have a question for you
today so
why don't you and other uh progressive
host shows
start like a a joint show like a network
such as like
cnn or fox news and such except
obviously a lot more left-leaning
yeah you know i've been asked this a
bunch of different times it's
it's just not it that's a lot of work
building
infrastructure that i don't know how
much we really benefit from like i get
the idea of
um uh you know working together it can
be more than the sum of the parts i get
that but it's
i'm just not i just want to keep growing
my show for the time being
let's listen to another one so i wanted
to apologize for
talking so much on your line um i
actually had a
jewish boyfriend in middle school
who shut down this place it was like a
like a place for little teens or
something like that
but um he ended up working there because
i
um i was sent there uh when i was
younger
all right another voicemail
um but i've uh i've been socializing a
lot with uh spanish people
as well down here and uh they're like
just
super super pushy and spanish people are
pushy
wow okay here's another one okay i'm
wondering
if the 535 of them in the capitol
building in their subgroups have more
wealth
the day trump leaves office we're in a
little different place they're going to
govern during the trump years
15 trillion dollars away from us so the
cupboards are bare
we are poor and they got more but
also this time the well is dry yes
exactly um
i think this might be the is this the
eggman or it's the same area code
hey dave and pat you guys know what the
corkage fee is
yeah corkages you bring your some
restaurants let you bring your own wine
and the the restaurant charges you to
open the bottle
i mean i get it right like they'd rather
sell you the wine obviously
but uh cor corkage the word bothers me
and the concept maybe bothers me even
more
you bring your own wine into a
restaurant they charge you money but
they service you
you have to pay court they open it for
you i charge corkage when people come to
my house for dinner actually
dude i would find out what the corkage
fee for all your
uh uh [ __ ] that you drink pat
oh my god soylent you gotta find out the
soylent
corkish fee before you get on a cruise
ship we were joking today on well eggman
is really responding almost in real time
we had a perfect bonus show today and we
talked about
uh the cruise industry and just i have
no interest i've never been on a big
cruise and i get sort of seasick anyway
and also it's like a stomach bug
petri dish i just have no interest in
cruising anyway and especially now that
um
you know with the virus the last thing i
want to do is go on a cruise
but we were talking about if pat went on
a cruise
would there be sufficient vegan food
available on the cruise or would he
bring soylent and i had the idea
you should bring a pallet of soylent
which pat sometimes takes with him on
trips
but ask the the restaurants on the boat
to serve it to you in a fancy way like
order a soylent and it's really your
soylent you brought
and they bring it out on you know in
like a martini glass or whatever
and the eggman is saying there might be
a corkage fee
for soylent yeah so that's good
so um i'm having a hard time like
socializing with people because
um i have to i guess like lie a lot it's
just like
that sounds tough and everyone here
seems to have like a really strong
stomach
i have like a really weak stomach so
it's like if i have to like
you know say stuff that's not true i
start to kind of like
feel like there's a vomit like rising in
my stomach
geez okay and then um
here's one last one on lab leak i guess
i just saw your clip regarding trump's
uh lab league theory
trump's theory yeah i know this but the
genetic sequence of the
sars kobe 2 virus the idea of trump
having a theory is a bit of an
overstatement
thanks to terms c g g
z g g
this sequence doesn't appear in nature
it's a marker that's used by virologists
to denote where they've made a splice in
the genetic code
it pretty much rules out anything but
a laboratory creation of this
have a good day all right
now um okay yeah i talked about lab leak
yesterday with dr
ashish i i just i don't have i don't
know
you know i spoke about it with dr ashish
i'm not going to now have a whole thing
with this guy
about cdg gbd so you know this type of
stuff
i want to say thank you to matt jenkins
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code
juneteenth good only until juneteenth
also thank you to chris duncan who just
also signed up on my website with the
coupon code juneteenth we are here for
joe biden
signing into law the federal holiday of
juneteenth
the right is triggered and we
are partially celebrating it with a
secret unpublished coupon code
juneteenth you've got to know how to
spell it to take advantage of it
i also want to say thank you over on
twitch to elora likes noodles for the
twitch sub
goulash joshua
has also signed up via twitch prime
um remember if you have amazon prime
do not leave your five bucks a month in
the pocket of jeff bezos
do not do it uh throw it to someone even
if it's not
our twitch channel but many many options
other super chats coming in marjorie
taylor pacman says flight of ideas in
real time seek help
please jeffrey says hey david stephen
colbert has a facebook hashtag called he
who shall be named
here's my name for trump the hippopotus
uh serge says your hat's missing ryden
with biden
have you heard the leaked conversation
between mansion and no labels i have
david did we get an explanation for the
hat yet in the stream no i don't owe you
an explanation
dean quite frankly i'm just wearing a
hat it's a bad hair day
that's all no uh no big deal
i want to say thanks to trey williams
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code
juneteenth um okay let me get on to a
few other things
things are going wild on our
tick tocks uh the managers of tick tocks
have been seeing what we've been doing
and they called and said
sir what on earth is happening 36k on
tick tocks 51k
on tick tocks 25k 36k
15k uh okay this one's not so good but
80 000 on tick tocks
and um this is all really this is our
new producer john he's been he's been
killing it on tick tocks
we've got a lot of exciting things
hopefully coming up um
teen acting star casey simpson is a
follower of the show
and big on tick tocks and we may soon be
doing a live with him
about getting young people involved in
politics
and that's going to be a big thing so
a lot a lot a lot is happening um here's
a scheduled piece of content this is
hold on is this muted yeah
this is me talking to dr ashish about
the lab leak let's take a quick
let's know where this virus came from we
want to understand it not just because
it helps us
manage this one but prevent future ones
but the other part
is we have got to stop politicizing this
like my god at this point we have
managed to take this thing that's a very
complicated and important scientific
question
and people are talking about it as
though like if you're a democrat you
believe one thing in a republican you
believe another
i just don't know the right answer we
need to investigate it we need to push
china to give us
more cooperation we need to have the us
intelligence and other
intelligence agencies investigated we
really do need to get to the bottom
bottom of this again if i were a betting
person i'd say
probably came from an animal but we're
not we're not making bets here we should
actually sort it out
we want to know where there it is so
that is dr
ashish jaw um that's a clip we're going
to be posting on the tick tocks
uh pretty pretty soon i would say
actually here is the event getting ready
for the signature of juneteenth as an
official federal holiday we are
celebrating this today
with a coupon code on our website
juneteenth
you've got to figure out how to spell it
that's the prerequisite but a lot of
people
taking advantage of that update on the
oh let's see if we can do this now
update on the new youtube channel i am
going to use my new if you're just
joining us i now have a stream deck i
have a single button
what on earth is that oh my god
i'm sorry about that anyway i have a
single button now
that should post the link into twitch
and youtube yes it did
um we are trying to get our first 5 000
subscribers
on the pacman live channel very exciting
we have our first video with the new
thumbnail format as you can see here it
is the diamond and silk mango video
i love looking at this and just seeing
funny things that have been
picked from the live streams you could
appear on this
channel because it is pacman live
content
viewer outraged over david's garden
let's see what that is that sounds
interesting
what's going on here i have an ad
blocker
but the ad is trying to play but it's
not even playing
ah here we go now do people want me to
preview
what the garden looks like today i've
not shown you my garden for weeks
everything is robe most things are
robust my chard
isn't looking good we're going to be
publishing that to the new
youtube channel soon but do people want
to see what is going on
um i last time i showed my garden i got
an angry email from someone saying
don't you dare show us your stink weeds
people want to see it all right okay
anyway
so um it's it's all it's all happening
and
um right now listen if you want to hold
for the long
term this is the time to get in we've
we're down to our last we have 50
memberships left now only 40 memberships
left before the first 5 000 on the new
channel
are spoken for so uh really strong
opportunity
for people to get in on that as we stand
by here
for wow so this feed we just completely
lost the white house feed has not gone
live yet but it should be starting
pretty soon a mess who's brian heffely
that's weird
it's like what are we even looking at
here
some people were in the first 500 yeah
no that's exciting
it's all very very exciting um
there are also some really interesting
things planned for the channel yeah it's
we're just trying it people get mad at
everything you know we're just trying a
new channel that's all
um all right so
i don't know what's happening with these
feeds but we're going to keep an eye on
for them enrique says cool hat i love it
bettina says one of your caps is on the
way to denmark today
nice jacob says sir why does the right
complain about being silenced when
youtube spams ads for ben shapiro matt
walsh etc
not only that the top performing uh
posts basically every day on facebook
are ben shapiro and dan bongino
they're like the top two people every
single day
every single day um
i think that's that's it as far as that
goes nathaniel
hein has just signed up on my website
with the coupon code
juneteenth and his new member number 19.
i also want to say thank you to adenan
dad who games bike shop guru
david krappenshitz i get it guys i get
it um
four new members via twitch that's
numbers 20
21 22
and 23. um
who am i watching lately for cooking
content oh
i have been you know uh
jacques pepin is the guy to watch it's
just the best that there was recently
a great piece on him on um
i think cbs this morning or something
like that
he's just the best let's see what new
jacques papa videos we have
it's just it's total zen pork roast with
ratatouille
beef with root vegetable
pork roast i don't want to do a pork
video it's a little bit crass if i don't
eat pork
let's see jacques new mac and cheese
video
jacques is the best 85 years old really
a national treasure
for which country i don't know since
he's french and american i'm jack pepa
and i'm cooking at home
he's just the best american classic mac
and cheese
everyone loves mac and cheese and i'm
going to do
a little bit of a white sauce here i
have a tablespoon and a half
of butter and i'm going to put a
tablespoon and a half
of flour in there right making a roux a
cup and a half of milk
so it's sold one and a half one and a
half one half cup of milk and i have one
and a half cup
of dry macaroni here love it which when
i cook them as you see is three cup
basically double one and a half cup of
macaroni roast about five ounces
five ounces of macaroni of course you
can do that with penne
or with any of type of pasta which is
the same thing you know beautiful
so here we go the white sauce
one one and a half
okay mix your roux there
if you want to know why i'm not aware of
the last thing that jimmy dore
said or the latest conflict it's because
i'm watching this stuff
instead of other stuff like what i do
this is very simple
to do as soon as it's mixed like this
it's fine cup cup and a half of milk
beautiful it'll come to a boil
salt pepper
[Music]
i put out about half a teaspoon of
paprika in there
but i love the paprika a three quarter
of a cup of panko
i'm gonna put about about a tablespoon
at the most of olive oil in there
otherwise it tends to uh
it tends to burn and i'm going to put
that in the oven this is the crust
to go on top see okay anyway so that's
who i recommend for cooking videos right
now as well as
of course of course of course the
toontoon channel
which is a really really strong cooking
channel do i have a catchphrase can you
imagine me having a catchphrase no way
did i see ruben's public meltdown on
masks no
can anybody tell me where to find that
that sounds hilarious
let me say thank you to malik lindell
taylor allen for signing up with the
coupon code juneteenth
as we see biden lori starr signing up
with code juneteenth
and alexis magana signing up with coupon
code juneteenth let's listen
ladies and gentlemen we got him
also thanks to kimberly thomas [ __ ] for
the juneteenth subscription
good afternoon everyone good afternoon
[Music]
so throughout history juneteenth has
been known by many names
jubilee day freedom day
liberation day mute that one here we go
emancipation day
and today a national holiday
and looking out across this room
i see the advocates the activists
the leaders who have been calling for
this day for so long
including the one and only miss opal lee
[Applause]
we just received a very special
recognition president of the united
states
and i see members of congress members of
the congressional black caucus
members of the united states senate who
passed
this bill unanimously and all
all of whom collectively were
responsible
for delivering this bill to the
president's desk and i
thank you all we thank you all your
nation
thanks you all and you know
when we establish a national holiday it
makes an important statement
national holidays are something
important
these are days when we as a nation
have decided to stop and take
stock and often to acknowledge
our history and so as we establish
juneteenth as our newest national
holiday
let us be clear about what happened on
june 19th
1865. right the day we call juneteenth
because you see that day was not the end
of slavery in america
yes on that day the enslaved people
of galveston texas learned that they
were free right
but in fact two and a half years earlier
the emancipation proclamation ended
slavery in the confederacy
we talked about this on the bonus show
today for more than two years
the enslaved people of texas were kept
in servitude
for more than two years they were
intentionally
kept from their freedom for more than
two years
and then on that summer day 156
years ago the enslaved people of texas
learned the news they learned that they
were free
and they claimed their freedom
it was indeed an important day
and still let us also remember that day
was not the end of slavery in america
the truth is it would be six more months
before the 13th amendment was ratified
before enslaved people in the south in
the north were free
so as we commemorate the history of
juneteenth
as we did just weeks ago with the
history of the tulsa
race massacre we must learn
from our history and we must teach our
children
[Music]
our history because it is part
of our history as a nation
it is part of american history
so let me end by saying this we are
gathered here
in a house built by enslaved people
we are footsteps away from where
president abraham
signed lincoln emancipation proclamation
and we are here to witness
president joe biden established
juneteenth as a national holiday we have
come
far and we have far to go but today
is a day of celebration it is not only a
day of pride
it is also a day for us to
reaffirm and rededicate ourselves to
action
and with that i say happy juneteenth
everybody
and with that i introduce the president
of the united states
joe biden uh what a day
thanks to chris coyne for the juneteenth
membership i appreciate that chris
[Applause]
well thank you uh madam vice president
156 years ago
156 years june 19th 1865.
john thanks for being here major general
of the
union army arrived in galveston texas
to enforce the emancipation proclamation
sorry for people asking it is a federal
holiday
i don't believe it will be a bank type
holiday where everybody
would be off the day as you all know and
repeat some of what was said
i think it's like flag day do you all
know that
a day that reflects what the psalm tells
us
weepy may endure for a night but joy
cometh in the morning juneteenth
marks both the long hard
night of slavery and subjugation
and a promise of a brighter morning to
come
this is a day profound in my view
profound weight and profound power
a day in which you remember the
moral stain the terrible
toll that slavery took on the country
and continues to take what i've long
called
america's original sin
at the same time i also remember the
extraordinary capacity
to heal and hope and to emerge
from those painful moments in a bitter
bitter
version of ourselves but to make a
better version
of ourselves now today
we consecrate juneteenth for what it
ought to be
what it must be a national holiday as
the vice president noted
a holiday that will join the others of
our
national celebrations our independents
our laborers who built this nation our
service men
and women who served and died in this
defense
in the first new national holiday since
the creation of martin luther king
holiday nearly four decades ago
83 grateful to the members of congress
here today in particular
the congressional black caucus who did
so much to make this
day possible i'm especially pleased that
we showed the nation that we can come
together as democrats and republicans
to commemorate this day with an
overwhelming bipartisan support of the
congress
i hope this is the beginning of a change
and
the way we deal with one another we're
blessed
we're blessed to mark the day in the
present miss opal lee
as my mother said god
[Applause]
a bit of a cold on the return from
europe
in nevada more than a year ago she told
me she loved me and i believed it
i wanted to believe it
[Laughter]
was over you're incredible a daughter of
texas
grandmother of the movement to make
juneteenth the federal holiday
and ms opal is uh you won't believe it
she's 49 years old i'm 94 years old but
i
you are an incredible woman this opal
you really are
as a child growing up in texas she and
her friends it's cringy but funny would
celebrate juneteenth
i don't know the juneteenth 1939
when she was 12 years old the white
white mob torched her family home
but such hate never stopped her
anymore to stop the vast majority of you
i'm looking at
from this podium over the course of
decades
she's made it her mission to see that
this day came
it was almost a singular mission she's
walked for miles and miles
literally and figuratively to bring
attention to juneteenth to make this day
possible
i ask once again we all stand and give
her a warm welcome
[Applause]
as they're still saying the senate and i
said for 36 years
if you excuse me for a point of personal
privilege
as i was walking down i regret that my
grandchildren aren't here
because this is a really really
really important moment in our history
by making juneteenth a federal holiday
all americans
can feel the power of this day and learn
from our history
and celebrate progress and grapple
with the distance we've come but the
distance we have to travel jim
and i said a few weeks ago marking 100th
anniversary of the tulsa race massacre
great nations don't ignore their most
painful moments
great nations don't ignore their most
painful moments
they don't ignore those moments in the
past they embrace them
great nations don't walk away
we come to terms with the mistakes we
made
and remembering those moments we began
to heal
and grow stronger the truth is
it's not simply not enough just to
commemorate
juneteenth after all
the emancipation of enslaved black
americans
didn't mark the end of america's work to
deliver on the promise of equality
it only marked the beginning to honor
the true meaning of juneteenth
we have to continue toward that promise
because we've not gotten there yet
the vice president i and our entire
administration and all of you in this
room
are committed to doing just that that's
why we've launched an aggressive effort
to combat racial discrimination
and housing finally addressed the cruel
fact that
a home owned to this day by a black
american
family is usually appraised at a low
rate for a similar home owned by a white
family in a similar
area that's why we committed to
increasing black home ownership
one of the biggest drivers of
generational wealth
that's why we're making it possible for
more black entrepreneurs to access
to access capital because their ideas is
good they lack the capital
to get their fare and get their fair
share of federal contracts
so they can begin to build wealth that's
why we're working to give each and every
child
three and four years of age not daycare
but school
in a school
[Music]
that's why right
that's why we're unlocking the
incredibly creative and innovation
and innovation of the history of our
historical black colleges
and universities providing them with the
resources invest in research centers and
laboratories
to help hbcu graduates prepare and
compete for good paying jobs in
industries of the future
folks the promise of equality
is not going to be fulfilled until we
become
real becomes real in our schools and on
our main streets and our neighborhoods
our health care system and ensuring that
equity is at the heart of our fight
against the pandemic
and the water that comes out of our
faucets in the air that we breathe in
our communities
in our justice system so we can fulfill
the promise of america for
all people all of our people
and it's not going to be fulfilled so
long as the sacred
right to vote remains under attack
you see this assault from restrictive
laws
threats of intimidation voter purges and
more
an assault that offends the very
democracy our very democracy we can't
rest so the promise of equality is
fulfilled for every one of us in every
corner of this nation
that to me is the meaning of juneteenth
that's what it's about so let's make
this
to this very juneteenth tomorrow
the first that our nation will celebrate
all together
as one nation but juneteenth
of action on many fronts one of those
is vaccinations tomorrow the vice
president will be in land on the bus
tour helping to spread the word like all
of you been doing
on life-saving vaccines right and across
the country this weekend including here
in washington people will be canvassing
and hosting events in their communities
going door-to-door encouraging
vaccinations
we've built equity into the heart of the
vaccination program from day one
but we still have more work to do to
close the racial gap and vaccination
rates
i love the door-to-door if you're an
anti-vaxxer and someone shows up and
says
i can inject you with something right
now most anti-vaxxers won't be convinced
by that
but for people who just think it's
inconvenient i think it's fantastic
a killer motivated by hate
intending to start a race war in south
carolina
he joined his victims in a bible study
class
then he took their lives in the house of
worship
it's a reminder that our work to root
out
hate never ends because hate only hides
it never fully goes away it hides
and when you breathe oxygen under that
rock
it comes out that's we must understand
that june 18th represents not only the
commemoration of the end of slavery
in america more than 150 years ago but
the ongoing work they have to bring
true equity and racial justice
into american society which we can do
in short this day doesn't just celebrate
the past
it calls for action today
i wish all americans a happy juneteenth
i'm certainly gonna in a moment gonna
sign on the law
making the federal holiday and i have to
say to you
i've only been president for several
months
but i think this will go down for me
it's one of the greatest honors
i will have had as president not because
i did it you did it
democrats and republicans but it's an
enormous enormous honor
thank you for what you've done and by
the way typical of most of us
in congress and senate i went down the
other end of the hall first and thanked
your staffs because i know who does the
hard work
there at the other end but i thank them
as well
right may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you now
i'd like to invite up while i sign
senator tina smith
senator ed markey senator raphael
warnock senator john cornyn
whip john clyburn cornyn representative
barbara lee
representative danny davis
chair joyce beatty
and sheila jackson lee and miss opal
i don't fully understand cornyn's
presence but okay
[Music]
thanks to odw for the 20 subs gifted on
twitch appreciate that
oh it's cornyn's bill okay well you
should be there then good for cornyn
thank you
no beau bert here shockingly
[Music]
so we've got the whole team sheila
jackson lee and ed markey raphael
warnock cornyn is up there
james clyburn
other folks
shouldn't he be using like an oversized
sharpie weird man
significant room tone in this room
they're using thank you
got three
[Music]
thanks to jamie doncho for signing up
with the code juneteenth
[Music]
all right
folks they did it completely meaningless
economically in just about every sense
but something that they were able to do
and it's a nice thing
it's a nice thing is election day next
mr president
is election day next week
mr president is election day next is the
plan to sign election day a national
holiday
all right well thank everybody
sir is election day
this is actually the type of stuff biden
is really good at like trump couldn't
relate to people in this way where he
just he'll hang out and talk to people
biden is known for this
and that doesn't necessarily get you
bills passed but it is a breath of fresh
air that's for absolute certainty
[Music]
so there it is juneteenth signed in as a
federal holiday
not of sort of like the first tier
which are you know bank holidays um
but a a holiday nonetheless sort of
equivalent to
like a flag day i think is what we would
um
we would say and that's uh
that's not bad is this usher right here
did anybody see that
is i didn't i only saw it for a second
is this usher the musician
is that actually who it is
i could have sworn that that was usher
anybody know
it is usher people know it's usher okay
[Music]
it's not usher very good it's definitely
not not usher okay excellent no it is it
is i can tell that it is
all right very good so um listen
appreciate everybody joining me
uh whoa that just ended very quickly
serpent with feet coming up next
anybody who is an expert in the stream
deck
technical element and has some ideas for
what and how i should set
certain things up uh please email me
info davidpakman.com if people have a
you know funny trump soundboard elements
that i could have on it whatever just
send me stuff and i'll start setting it
up
and we're gonna see everybody so soon
thank you for joining me and um of
course a coupon code juneteenth
good until saturday or forever depending
on who you want to believe